for this week's classic interview yes
classic interview on a Thursday instead
of Friday even though it's Thursday it's
kind of the Friday show in a way but on
a Thursday we're going to just a good
old-fashioned clueless right-winger this
is an interview I did with Josh
Bernstein shortly after the lifting of
the Cuban embargo what will Donald Trump
ultimately do with the Cuban embargo we
don't really know it's anyone's guess he
said many many things about it
complicated things as Donald Trump would
like to say anyway see if you can even
follow the logic of what Josh Bernstein
was trying to argue during this
interview I'm joined today by Josh
Bernstein he is a spokesman for a Mac
also a radio talk show host strategist
writer the topic today is the Cuban
embargo we of course talked to you
recently about how President Obama
indicated that we would be resuming a
normalization of diplomatic relations
with Cuba looking to open an embassy
there at some point Josh if I have read
what you've written correctly you're
against this tell us why well I think
that it sets a dangerous precedent that
we are now negotiating openly and freely
with dictatorships and dictatorship
countries Cuba being one of them this
embargo has been there for a long time
they treat their their people their
human rights abuses they're number nine
on the world's list for human rights
abuses so I just don't see that they
have earned the right to have this
embargo lifted and then I also look at
the fact that I believe because
President Obama does not like to be
repudiated in his policies he wanted to
close Guantanamo Bay way back when in
2009 he was not able to do that so by
normalizing these relations this will
then take some of that pressure off of
him and I believe that this is
ultimately the goal is to close
Guantanamo Bay which I believe would
also be a geopolitical mistake being
that the relationship between Russia and
Cuba is so strong all right well I don't
think that in the time President Obama
has left this president no matter what
happens
Guantanamo Bay is going to be closed so
but we could disagree on that but let's
at least put that aside for the for the
immediate time so it sounds like
the standard you're using to determine
whether the US should have or not have
embargoes or whether we we should have
or not have diplomatic relations is
whether we're dealing with the regime
that as you said is harsh against its
own people you don't like the regime
element of Cuba and based on that you
don't agree with the lifting of the
embargo I don't agree with the lifting
of the embargo because I don't really
see how it would benefit America and if
we were so steadfast on lifting this
embargo then we would have said okay
fine how about 24 months with verifiable
proof that you have made the revisions
in your country to allow people to be
free to allow people to vote to allow
people to own you know different
properties and things like that and not
find people up for their political
disagreements and execute them like has
been done in the past now have you been
advocating for the cease of American
support and diplomatic relations with
the current regimes in Uganda Rwanda
Bahrain Turkmenistan Tajikistan
Uzbekistan Vietnam Saudi Arabia we have
huge diplomatic relations with China a
huge human rights abuser would you end
relations with all of those as well
based on the same rubric you've
established with Cuba well I think that
when you let's take China for instance
China is a very different animal you
have over a billion people you have a
huge economy unfortunately now has taken
over the United States economy has the
world's largest economy and personally
in my personal agreement my belief
system no I don't think we should
negotiate with any third-world regime
terrorist nation if you will that is a
sponsor of terrorism in my opinion okay
and do you understand the economic
impact that it would have given the
economic connection between China and
the US if we were to cease that
relationship completely in the same
fashion that you support maintaining
with Cuba in the sense that if you
consider the amount of American bonds
that are held by China China has
financed much of what we have happening
in the United States we get so many of
our products from China
the profits of so many American
companies that I presume you support are
derived from the fact that we're using
inexpensive labor in China you would
forego all of that stuff and you would
accept all of the impacts it would have
on the economy well I think that if
you're taking that all of that into
consideration I think that we need a new
China policy I believe that we ought to
put more tariffs on their goods coming
in and out of their country
but Walmart era hero you only have
tariffs with a country with which you do
have relations right which is something
that that you joined idea would totally
end with China well I'm not saying that
we would end it because again we're it's
too intertwined
this isn't you know this isn't eleven
million people and an embargo for 50
years
this is China that has been working with
the United States for years not that I
agree with the fact that we should be
working with communist countries but
it's kind of like the the the sale what
what does that have to do with the the
sale of tea in China well no but I think
the problem I'm having is you first
established what you said was your
standard for deciding whether or not we
should do business with the country when
I brought up China you first said you
would also agree with completely cutting
off all ties but then noise that a that
okay maybe I miss any relations to make
it more fair okay no what it sounds
really said was you wouldn't cut off all
relations with China because there's way
more people there and it would be more
logistical II complex so are you saying
that your standard your moral standard
for who the US should do business with
is in part informed by convenience no
not necessarily I like I said before I
think that with China being that you
know they have a huge economy and it has
been intertwined with us it would be
almost impossible to cut off that
relationship without detrimental
circumstances occurring from that
however I believe just like Mitt Romney
said back in 2012 which he was ridiculed
and laughed at that we ought to change
our policy and we ought to have more
tariffs on their goods because they do
get away with exploiting the labor and
having everything come in here I mean if
you do go if you do the Walmart
smart game and you look at ten items in
your house I guarantee you at least nine
out of those 10 are not going to be made
in America they're good horses yeah but
right now we're starting to splinter a
little bit from kind of the main theme
so Cuba you want the embargo China huge
human rights abuser there no embargo
we're just very tied in with them but
you would increase tariffs what about
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia one of the
most extreme fundamentalist Islamists
regimes they're beheading people we have
George W Bush who goes over and is
holding hands and kissing them would you
also if you're going to maintain an
embargo with Cuba
it would seem completely dishonest
intellectually to maintain any relations
whatsoever with Saudi Arabia right well
the thing is with Saudi Arabia is we
already had Barack Obama go over there
and kneel down in front of them and
kisses kiss the ring but getting that to
the side with Saudi Arabia hopefully
what's going to happen is that North
Dakota and Colorado and you know
Louisiana and some of these other places
that are now starting to say to the
Environmental Protection Agency we don't
care what you say we're going to start
drilling and showing you that we're
going to you know produce our own oil
and I believe that hopefully we will
take some of that that relationship away
at some point and we won't be relying on
foreign oil as much as we start drilling
here in America and producing our own
resources here at home so to answer your
question I don't believe we should have
very close relations with almost any
regime and to think that we want to lift
an embargo against a communist nation
meanwhile we want to take our closest
ally Israel and we want to put sanctions
on them and force them to somehow come
up with some kind of state to with the
Hamas and Hezbollah factions near Israel
is just ludicrous
yeah well listen I agree with you
there's no negotiating with Hamas but
again I think that's a bit of a
distraction here's where I see it Josh
you know what I hear from you is you're
saying embargo with Cuba China and Saudi
Arabia are bad in my opinion we could do
hours of programming as to why they're
way worse than Cuba but with China
you're willing to increase tariffs in a
way that won't really hurt our economy
and and so on and so forth
with Saudi Arabia yeah they're bad but
if and when we can get off of the
foreign oil that they provide then maybe
you would do something about it and when
you look at Cuba Cuba is a country that
you're using communist kind of as an ad
hominem but the reality is Cuba poses no
threat to us this embargo is leftover
political posturing from the Cold War
we're doing nothing good for the Cuban
people or American businesses who would
want to do business there by keeping
this embargo going and if the idea hold
on a second hold on a second Josh :
and if the idea is that by maintaining
the embargo we're going to change their
system of government we know from
experience from the last decade that
that's not going to happen so I don't
see what the what are we gaining by
maintaining this embargo what are we
gaining by opening it up I don't believe
that we're gaining anything at all
because I mean Mariela Castro Raul's
daughter herself said the Americans are
fools if they absolutely think that
somehow they're going to hit the no
communist button and then all of a
sudden turn to democracy we know that's
not going to happen you just mentioned
that communist regimes stay typically
communist regimes Marco Rubio let's not
forget a Cuban immigrant his parents
came here from Cuba they know how bad
the Castro regime is he said thank God
he's now going to be the chairman of the
Foreign Relations Committee he said that
they're not going to lift the embargo
which is good the Senate would need to
confirm anyone that would be to be in
place for the embassy that he wants to
create revenue ajami what you and I are
what I'm the conversation I'm trying to
have with you is about the sense of this
not whether Marco Rubio would allow it
in committee or not I mean we again we
have a situation here where we are
restricting Americans ability to travel
to Cuba we are spending a lot of money
enforcing that we spend money enforcing
the embargo this is so far from fiscally
conservative you could open that up as a
market for American businesses and bring
in additional revenues and in addition
you could open up that as
as an area where we don't need to spend
money enforcing an embargo it would be
hugely fiscally conservative and again
the double standard with the other ten
regimes we currently have have business
would shows us that the regime argument
alone is morally bankrupt well again
like I said I don't see again I'm going
to respectfully disagree with you I
don't see any benefit of opening up this
embargo none whatsoever but that
definitely has that may be your opinion
Josh but we have analyses that
televising at the communist regime David
in my opinion and what are we doing and
what are we doing in Saudi Arabia why
have you not been writing articles about
cutting off Saudi Arabia as opposed to
well maybe if we can depend a little
less on their oil
I would suggest some sanctions it's a
huge double standard job sanctions don't
work sanctions gives money to communist
regime sanctions give money to prop up
dictatorships we already know that they
don't work I mean even with Iran the
only thing that's going to change with
Saudi Arabia Iran Iraq any of these
places is getting away from foreign
interest as far as oil and and basically
depending on them so I would love to see
a reset in American policy in which we
drill baby drill here at home rather
than you know getting 70 percent of our
oil and imports from other countries so
I answer your question
communism is communism no matter where
it is I would love to see it end
everywhere but we know that that's just
not the reality I mean what's going to
happen next we're going to normalize
relations with North Korea are we going
to normalize relations now and drop
sanctions against Iran so again you know
I understand what your argument is and
the fact that we have done business for
a long time with some of these other
countries I get that but again for me I
would rather see us not you know I gotta
tell you what you're saying is that no
matter what other countries were doing
business with no matter what the experts
say would be the economic benefit of
lifting the embargo you just don't want
it to happen and I think that that's
coming in so very I don't see the
benefit no I would read all of the
reports about what the fact that Russia
I see this as a catalyst to being able
to close Guantanamo Bay which I believe
is a strategic military location for us
93 miles away
is-is-is cuba and they would then fill
that vacuum if we were to leave and I
believe that they already have a cozy
relationship for 50-plus years
communists to communists whether you
want to call Russia communist now or not
doesn't really matter because we know
Vladimir Putin said in 2005 the greatest
geopolitical catastrophe
in the twentieth century was the fall of
communist relationship with Cuba might
actually be a way to put a wedge between
Cuba and Russia I think that you're just
not I think you're way off on this but I
do respect the fact that you came on and
talked to me about it we've been
speaking with Josh Bernstein spokesman
for a Mac radio host etc etc Josh thank
you thank you